these are the voyages of the starship
enterprise
its five-year mission to explore strange
new worlds
to seek out new life and new
civilizations
to boldly go where no man has gone
before
for a woman and boldly go they did those
familiar opening words
are from the star trek television series
from the 1960s
the show was set far into the future in
the 23rd century to be exact
but it was forward thinking in some
other important ways
from the controversial social issues it
often addressed
to its multiracial multicultural cast
something unheard of in television of
the time now a new documentary shows how
that
imagined diversity became reality it's
the true story
of how star trek actress michelle
nichols played a key role
in nasa's effort to recruit both people
of color
and the first female astronauts more
than four
decades ago
captain i'm picking up the alien signal
again
but it's coming from inside the
enterprise she was one of star trek's
now
legendary characters ship the ship
healing frequencies open sir lieutenant
can you played by actress michelle
nichols
give me that i'll protect you
sorry neither the no-nonsense
communications officer whose very
presence
communicated something powerful to
viewers
and fans alike
i'm afraid i changed my mind she wasn't
playing some stereotypical role
she wasn't a maid or a nanny or anything
among them
benjamin crump the civil rights attorney
best known for representing the families
of trayvon martin
and george floyd progress report she was
the third highest ranking member
in a space command i mean you talk about
every little black boy and girl running
to the tv to say
hello that's a black woman and she's in
charge
see in our century we've learned not to
fear words
may i present our communications officer
lieutenant [ __ ] this is a fight for our
children
krump and director todd thompson whom we
met at the johnson space center
are executive producers of woman in
motion
michelle nichols star trek and the
remaking
of nasa the rollout of nasa's space
shuttle orbiter 101
why don't we know the story i think a
lot of things happen in history that you
just take for granted and don't pay any
attention to until it's time to
pay attention to it and michelle's story
in particular is so
monumental that i think deserves our
attention deserves our
respect
star trek wasn't a big hit its first
year on the air
nichols was actually planning to leave
the show to pursue a career on broadway
that is until she met someone else very
conscious of the impact she was having
it was civil rights icon the reverend
martin luther king jr
a devout trekkie who told nichols star
trek was the only tv show he'd watched
with his children
and pleaded with her to stay aboard the
starship
enterprise he said you don't understand
the effect
that you are having not only on black
people
not only on young women but on everybody
and stay she did making even more
history with american television's
first interracial kiss and the prize
this growing fame would soon transport
her from a fictional space program
to the real thing two
one nasa was coming off the apollo
program
they were gearing up for this new
exciting thing called the space shuttle
program
and they they needed a different class
of astronauts instead of
the traditional test pilot so because
they couldn't find any
they couldn't find any but mostly
because you know who would have thought
that
all the people working at nasa were huge
star trek fans for obvious reasons
so nasa started showing up at the star
trek conventions as well she gave a
speech
to nasa because of lieutenant uhura
and the success of star trek and when
she looked out in the audience
she said she didn't see any women
she didn't see any minorities and so she
said
where are my people
and i meant that then and i mean it now
there was one person in that room who
was really listening in
yeah it was the head of nasa and so
they came and they met with her and they
challenged her
they said you know literally will you
help us
reluctant first nichols accepted the
challenge
forming the company women in motion and
embarking upon a year-long mission
to change the face of nasa hi
i'm michelle nichols but i still feel a
little bit like lieutenant
on the starship enterprise she shot this
recruitment film here at the space
center
seeking astronauts for the shuttle
program so that is why
i'm speaking to the whole family of
humankind
minorities and women alike this is your
nasa
and she literally went to every
major city around the country every
historically black college and
university and what she's saying
nasa needs you history needs you
and soon enough star trek's fantasy
prediction of a more diverse future
took a step closer to reality thanks to
nichols
8 000 people applied to nasa's 1978
astronaut class in all 35 new recruits
were chosen
including for the first time six women
and four people of color all six of the
women that were
recruited during that 1978 class
and every single one of them would
be high-fiving michelle and you know
giving their thanks to her
for what she did nicole stott is a
retired shuttle astronaut
she says nichols brought an inspiring
seriousness and credibility to the
effort
she didn't want to be this mascot for
nasa
she wanted to be a strong independent
powerful voice for this population that
hadn't been
represented by nasa yet so that it would
be believable and i think that's what
those women would say
is that it was believable and they were
encouraged to
pick up the pen and fill out the
application now 88 years old nichols is
out of the public eye but in interviews
for the documentary
she recalled that time when she was as
determined as the characters she played
to help women and people of color cross
a final frontier
of opportunity well this might sound a
little
corny but it felt like
my children and my heart
it pounded and i knew
the world would never be the same again
we would go on to great heights
and to think that
[Music]
i had the slightest thing to do with it
[Music]
makes me know that all
things good are possible
all things good are possible i didn't
know this story i'd heard of hidden
figures the human
uh computers the african-american women
like katherine johnson
but these were the the people out front
who were going to be the face of nasa so
it's incredible what she was able to do
and the number of applications they got
right after in just four months she did
that
i love how she not only then recognized
her role as a role model
but then fully embraced it and spoke
sort of truth to power in that moment
remarkable